jean claude mailly le secrétaire général
de force ouvrière est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir au moment où la
france connaît de nouveaux blocages sur
fond de grogne sociale la sncf bien sûr
mais également les intermittents et la
liste n'est pas close la fronde huyse le
gouvernement mais aussi indirectement
avec les intermittents jean claude
mailly est bien la gestion paritaire de
l'assurance chômage c'est à dire votre
signature manuel valls contesté
également par une frange de la majorité
on le sait sur le pacte de
responsabilité vous les rejoignent et
manuel valls qui s'affiche déterminé de
son côté à poursuivre les réformes avec
moi ce soir pour vous interroger jean
philippe jauniaux de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire comme
chaque semaine à la preuve par trois
avec dailymotion et bien sûr perrine
tarneaud de public sénat les cheminots
de la cgt et de sud-rail ne désarme pas
donc contre une réforme qui ne change
rien à leur statut on ne cesse de le
répéter la grève ou l'envoi également
des drapeaux force ouvrière n'a t'elle
pas trop duré non mais attendez un autre
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui les
il ya une réforme qui est commence à
discuter au parlement aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale il ya des
cheminots qui ont des inquiétudes sa
porte pas directement sur le statut
d'ailleurs des cheminots c'est faux bien
souvenir qu'en 97 sur injonction à
l'époque déjà mais la france l'a accepté
de la commission européenne de l'union
européenne on a coupé en deux la sncf en
disant qu'il faut gérer les régions d'un
côté la sncf de laurent vallet
rassemblés suite à des courses tourisme
en uniqlo êtes sûr de ce qui à l'époque
n'était pas les seuls avait dit c'est
une manière de couper en deux la sncf ça
ne marchera pas c'est pas une vacation
aujourd'hui c'est pas une bonne solution
donc il faut effectivement réformer ce
système sauf que au lieu de reconstituer
à la limite je vais lire reconstituer la
sncf par exemple il ya pas ça c'est pas
possible
l'europe nous laisse nous l'interdît
donc on fait 3 epic un jeu rentrent pas
dans les établissements publics quelle
garantie quand même et qu'elle
garantisse et salin des problèmes de
fond quelles garanties ya deux problèmes
de fond selon moi quelles garanties on a
que demain et ben offre un epic on
mettra pas de côté et se sera privatisée
aujourd'hui au dieu ne vous inquiétez
pas mais sauf qu'on n'a pas les
garanties et deuxième de m la dette plus
de 40 milliards d'euros d'autres pays
ont réduit leur dette en france on n'a
pas réduit et d'être l'essentiel de la
dette provient des réseaux grog voilà
donc ça serait pas la même c'est une
évocation messieurs alors quoi de
meilleur sur l'aide sur la grève
rapporte donc plus d'une semaine ben oui
bêtement continue par expérience qu'il
faut conserver qui décide c'est pas
c'est les cheminots fini si dociles
continuer ou pas une grève c'est d'abord
comme ça que ça se passe c'est pas
quelqu'un qui appuie sur un bouton
jamais tant cru si parfois ils essaient
d'ailleurs console redirection des entre
leur direction le dit puisqu'il paraît
que la cgt notamment une forte écoute et
vous a pas échappé que jusqu'à hier
général de fo unsa l'uqar est pas
représentatif mais j'ai vu des normes
d'aujourd'hui nos chaussures par région
nous sommes représentatifs et ça nous
empêche pas d'avoir une position et la
fédération fo des cheminots de forte
inquiétude également sur ce que je viens
ce que je viens d'expliquer quand on a
une situation de ce type par expérience
quand il ya un conflit il faut négocier
il faut négocier ça vaut y compris pour
le dessert c'est parce qu'on
arrivait devant la cpi quand il ya
encore un conflit on négocie parce que
s'il n'y a pas d'autres sorties
possibles il faut quand il ya un conflit
qui est un protocole d'accord à la fin
d'un conflit si on laisse pourrir une
situation dans un sens ou dans l'autre
si on de chacun joue les gros bras y
compris au gouvernement au gouvernement
il fait d'un acte d'autoritarisme c'est
un peu ça quand même pitroipa se permet
des commentaires certains mini se
permettent des commentaires sur les
organisations syndicales vous imaginez
si demain les syndicats et des
commentaires sur les partis politiques
où on va je pense pas que ce soit
intelligent comme technique de deux de
jouer à ça sauf que imaginer que pour
une raison ou une autre le bras de fer
continue bon courage pour gérer demain
où les épiques où la sncf en tant que
tel parce que ça va créer un climat
détestable je pense que quand on est
responsable et compris quand on est
ministre secrétaire d'état premier
ministre on prend ça on consacrait déjà
quoi en suspens on aurait pu se donner
un peu de temps je crois que mitterrand
donné il faut savoir donner du temps au
temps dit il ya des moments où il faut
savoir donner du temps au débat on
aurait pu on aurait pu attendre du
jargon jour il pourrait très bas d'hier
pour écouter allez on essaie de trouver
une solution à une sortie de crise parce
qu'il ya crise on trouve une solution de
sortie de crise on pouvait très bien
décider de suspendre à l'assemblée
trouver une solution combinant tu sais
pas quoi faire vous dites le moi de
faire vous dites au goût ferry a
toujours d'un bras ok mais vous dites au
gouvernement
oubliez les députés pour un temps et est
retourné voir les syndicats c'est pas
les députés qui sont en grave non sans
les
cheminots étaient entendus jusque là il
ya des cheminots qui sont en grève c'est
un constat ça on peut dire il ya tant de
crédit c'est un simple constat qu'est ce
qu'on fait on laisse une situation
déterminée comme ça bonjour demain dans
tous les cas de figure ou alors on est
responsable et on dit on essaie de
trouver une solution négociée un moment
donné voilà ça c'est l'expérience
syndicale qui me conduit à dire ce à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des conflits que
d'une manière ou d'une autre un bras de
fer s'est mal terminée que ce soit pour
une direction où les organisations
syndicales c'est bonjour le climat après
infogérés derrière ça démotive tout le
monde et c'est donc voilà c'est tout on
n'est pas dans la communication
permanente et c'est ça qui est trop
souvent le cas aujourd'hui les goûts
cité laurent berger de la cfdt ray lui
s'exprimer il dit il faut arrêter cette
grève a passé sa responsabilité moi je
me gave nous dit qu'il faut continuer
non c'est la bienvenue puisque mode et
même s'il sait c'est pas moi qui décide
la grève moi je n'ai pas l'habitude en
tant que syndicaliste de dénoncer des
salariés qui sont en grattant vous
soutenez le mouvement ah bah oui
contient mouvaux rigueur mais la
fédération fo des cheminots soutient le
mouvement de grève et je n'ai pas
l'habitude contient une grève de dire
non les salariés ont tort de faire grève
la grève s'est jamais un choix enfin si
c'est un choix mais c'est jamais pour
faire plaisir je vous rappelle quand
même que quand on est en grève on perd
son salaire donc c'est pas les payes des
cheminots c'est pas la paye de didier
migaud ou encore x des journées de grève
sont payés est ce que vous estimez qu'il
faudra payer les journées on n'en est
pas là aujourd'hui non mais si laquelle
ils sont en grève ce qui se discute et
on en
discutait aussi mettant des mets moi
dans tous les mouvements de grève que
j'ai connu c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai
à un moment donné ça fait partie côte il
ya une volonté de négociation est ce
qu'on appelle un protocole d'accord de
sortie de grève quand ça existe quelle
négociation kantien négociations ça fait
toujours d'accord dans bombay comme dans
pub en a compris votre position non
l'attendent mais faut il ya une grève et
ben par nature vous la soutenez ce que
vous avez quand même été choqué par le
peu de cas qui a été fait des lycéens
alors d'une batterie oui mais ça
landrier salle eugène une greffe chez
les cheminots sa gêne tout le temps
dit spinoza gêne des usagers oui mais
oui c'est gênant pour ceux qui ont su
d'accord choqué est-ce que ça messieurs
je suis pas passé le bac moi
c'est toujours gênant non mais c'est ce
que je comprends le lycéen ou la
lycéenne qui va passer son bac et qui
est déjà stressés par avance et qui
encore plus stressés
c'est dommage
non mais c'est vraiment dommage il
aurait fallu éviter ce type de situation
mais il fallait en sortir avant la grève
est annoncée 1 la grève est annoncée
jusqu'à faire des tas de nouveaux
transports ferry cuvillier appelle à un
pacte national pour assurer la pérennité
d'un modèle de service public français
dit il un pacte national à ses loyers en
mode ça il ya un pacte de responsabilité
il ya le pacte national moi j'appelle le
pacte d'austérité ce qu'on est en train
de faire en ce moment c'est ailleurs les
chocs maintenant il ya les pactes bon ça
ce sont ce sont des mots le modèle de
service public français ça vaut pas que
pour la sncf a en ce moment il est en
train d'être mis en cause le modèle
public sur le modèle entre guillemets
mais moi je ne suis pas franchement que
je ne pas la garantie nous n'avons pas
la garantie demain que pour une raison
ou une autre un epic tu deviens autre
chose dedans alors attendons que c'est
une loi obligatoire aux récentes rumeurs
alors c'est une grève par anticipation
meinau met on a tellement eu tellement
eu de cas où l'on vous inquiétez pas on
fait juste ça mais vous inquiétez pas
mais là on prend les garanties et puis
un an ou deux ans après les choses
changent on a eu ça c'est pas la
première fois rappelez-vous dans des
visas les 80 qu'on avait nationalisé
pour que les parentés puis après on a
restructuré et privatisé alors employé
vous avez cité le gouvernement qui est
inflexible vous le dénoncer un
vous avez vu directement manuel valls
qui vous a fait part de sa détermination
à bloquer pendant une grève ils pressent
dans sa part évoqué le particulièrement
le dossier des jeux de la cen cf on
n'était pas si ce n'est pas la réunion
ne portait pas là-dessus la réunion ils
multiplient pour la préparation oui de
la grande et vous sentir layton on y
reviendra mais ma passion c'est à faire
là wilson de meute et montre de la
fermeté de l'autorité ou d'autoritarisme
de l'autoriser un peu quand même et
n'est pas dans son rôle il faudrait que
ça chacun côté le premier ministre ou un
ministre quel qu'il soit continue à un
conflit dans lequel le gouvernement a
une part de responsabilité c'est lui qui
propose il a une part de responsabilité
est ce qu il veut aller continuer à bras
de fer ou est ce qu'à un moment donné il
faut discuter moi je suis a toujours un
partisan de la discussion de la
négociation alors on parle d'amour de du
mouvement des intermittents du spectacle
maintenant puisque là vous êtes sur la
même ligne que le gouvernement à jean
claude mailly puisque l'italie dans la
clio rip fronton du
gouvernement n'était pas sur la
validation de l'accord du 22 mars sur
l'assurance chômage pour faire que ça
concerne tout le monde à tous les
salariés passent devant les
interventions il ya des droits nouveaux
par exemple ce qu'on appelle les droits
rechargeables
est ce que vous réclamez néanmoins une
nouvelle négociation
peut-être qu'il ya un consensus au
gouvernement sur les annexes spécifique
nuitées disent non c'est pas possible à
ne pas avoir un peu pas dire ben on
négocie qu'une partie comme le nom
l'indiqué ce sont des annexes dont des
annexes un texte principal la
négociation le la négociation sur
l'accord sur l'assurance chômage qui
donne lieu ensuite l'écriture plus
technique d'une convention et c'est le
texte de la convention qui doit être
agréé ou pas par le gouvernement ça a
toujours été ça toujours est il qu'à
comme ça c'est la mécanique je dirais
juridique porte sur l'ensemble des
salariés et les alains qu'est ce qu'on
fait
nous nous avons signé c'est à dire que
nous avons pris nos responsabilités
quand on est d'accord on signe quand on
n'est pas d'accord on ne signe pas faut
bien comprendre cette négociation elle
porte sur 2 millions 700 mille personnes
indemnisées par le système d'assurance
chômage dont 400 mille parce qu'on
appelle les allocations d'état et 2
millions 300 mille directement par les
cotisations des salariés des employeurs
et il ya à peu près 95 milles
intermittents indemnisés aujourd'hui par
le système d'assurance chômage on amène
des garanties pour un million de
personnes à peu près de précaires avec
ce qu'on appelle les droits
rechargeables pour les salariés multi
employeurs etc il ya quelques efforts
demandés je vous rappelle que le
l'unedic qui financent l'essentiel de
pôle emploi c'est l'essentiel du
financement c'est aujourd'hui 18
milliards d'euros de déficits cumulés
alors même si la croissance reparte et
ça poserait des efforts demandés vous
les avez accepté
la présence certains cadres dans régime
général et il ya quelques efforts oui
demandé pour les intermittents mais il
faut bien comprendre les annexes 8 et 10
sont préservés le patronat voulait les
supprimer moi si demain l'état récupère
tout bébé il aura l'argent pour
maintenir un système ou alors on dira
banon on met plus d'un nexus 1010
cheminots qu'est ce que vous dites aux
intermittents ils n'ont pas compris
qu'on leur demande est forte il ya des
chiffres non un jeudi aux intermittents
les annexes sont maintenus 8 et 10 à qui
ça veut dire par exemple 75 à 76 % des
comédiens artistes etc ne sont pas
concernés par une des mesures qui est
contestée qui est le différé
dynamisation la moitié des intermittents
quels qu'ils soient auront un différé
d'indemnisation inférieure à douze jours
bon ça existe pas dit ça ça à l'effort
il ya du cumul possible entre revenus
d'activité indemnisation chômage donc
c'est préserver alors après on peut pas
tout mélanger moi je conçois bien ce que
je peux comprendre c'est quelqu'un est
intermittent c'est un statut de
l'intermittence c'est un régime
particulier quand vous avez les budgets
de la culture qui sont restreints je
cite et votre foi l'exemple du conseil
général de la creuse en deux ans
encadrés 5000 euros en moins bon mais où
ailleurs donc moins dead moins de
subventions publiques donc des
intermittents qui galèrent pour trouver
du boulot donc ça c'est pas le système
via les intermittents
les enfants portent sur l'intermittence
elle vous dites aux intermittents il
faut accepter la réponse est non je veux
attaquer c'est là il accepte tout y est
refusé c'est leur droit ce qui reste pas
l'endroit nous l'a signé et on va pas
renégocié les possessions elle est
terminée maintenant il ya des problèmes
à régler les problèmes à régler ce c'est
quoi le problème à régler c'est
notamment les audi
les directeurs de théâtres subventionnés
se plaignent voilà par exemple et ont
tendance à soutenir les techniciens et
les comédiens bon il ya quelques gisèle
autrefois en souriant je vais finir par
embaucher n'en a pas les moyens il faut
quelqu'un de connu tu vas faire là gens
comme ça en fera pas un manif on dire
vous ne trouvez 56 tes pieds même les
petites questions à vous poser sur le
sujet à savoir si vous estimez qu'il est
normal que ce soit les salariés du privé
qui finance la culture oui ou non c'est
pas la culture les intermittents du
spectacle oui mais c'est pas qu'on
finance pas la culture on a tenu compte
historiquement on sait force ouvrière
leur noble et oui c'est normal non mais
attendez c'est pas la culture ils ont
des contrats de travail particulier vous
travaillez après vous de fait vous êtes
comédiens vous est de faire des
répétitions et cetera même si dans le
temps les directeurs terre de payer les
répétitions maintenant parfois ils les
font payer à l'assurance chômage donc ça
c'est de la solidarité de la même
manière quand vous avez un régime de
retraite de salariés déficitaire
c'est une folie d'anormal car
aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas normal ce
qui n'est pas normal c'est que vous avez
certaines entreprises sont les
employeurs qui usent et abusent de
contrats nécessitait une production
notamment dans le oui mais pas
simplement pas ce lien de grands
entreprises qui ne sont pas dans
l'audiovisuel qui montent dans leur
service communication des gens à
fernande finir à 8 ans il devrait être
en cdi à peu près cent mille
intermittents aujourd'hui inutilisées
voilà jack lang soutient le mouvement
mais enfin il note que dans dix ans ce
chiffre a doublé ce bizarre bah oui mais
ça veut dire que des abus aussi d'antan
mais oui c'est ça ça doit être une des
choses à discuter qu est-ce que vraiment
doit avoir un cac natixis qu'un
intermittent neuf accords dans quel
réseau brille par services comme d'une
grande entreprise pense pas que ce soit
un travail d'appuis numéro un ça n'est
pas que 25 % du déficit de l'assurance
chômage soit représentée par les
intermittents qui sont simplement vous
avez % des 1 débrouillez vous savez que
là aussi les chiffres se discute puis
s'ils n'étaient pas des mises et c'est
ça a été évalué à 3
mais c'est une semaine de solidarité la
preuve que ouais vous êtes en train de
me dire mais c'est pas normal que les
annexes 8 et 10 une certaine manière
puisque ça coûte cher bas sinon on veut
les maintenir les annexes 8 et 10 et je
ne suis pas persuadé mois là où je mets
en garde des intermittents et si demain
non mais quand je disais mais on garde
les choses pour les mettre en garde oui
sur une chose je ne suis pas sur moi
demain que si tout était mis à plat il y
aura encore des annexes 8 et 10 donc
j'ai pas sûr dans la rue dans la période
d'austérité que nous vivons actuellement
et austérité budgétaire qu'une
gouvernement mettra les moyens à bien
ces on a entendu votre avertissement
très ferme aux intermittents mais qui
l'est beaucoup moins pour les cheminots
j'aurai les ont déjà su mener pour
assumer cette double opposition qui a
été très clair dans la première partie
de cette émission va maintenant évoquer
et bien votre contestation de la ligne
économique de manuel valls avec
notamment ce pacte de responsabilité qui
vous fait horreur jean claude mailly le
premier ministre on le sait est contesté
également par une partie de la gauche
mais il est conforté par la cour des
comptes qui appelle de son côté à de
nouvelles mesures choc pour réduire les
dépenses publiques avant d'accueillir
jean philippe jauniaux de la sp marie
brémond a tenté de savoir si la france
était impossible à réformer comparé à
l'italie apparemment en ce moment ça
semble le cas
cheminots chauffeur de taxi
intermittents on défile dans les rues de
france les motifs des manifestants les
réformes du gouvernement
quoi qu'il arrive vous avez finalement
une espèce de j'allais dire de refus
tout problème à prayssas et du politique
d'assumer affronte chaud et les choix
qu'ils proposent les dirigeants
politiques manquerait-il donc de courage
pour mener à bien les réformes en france
face aux protestations chez nos voisins
transalpins depuis quelques mois il y à
du changement dans l'air réforme fiscale
réforme du sénat suppression des
provinces nouveau code du travail rien
ne semble effrayer le récent président
du conseil matteo renzi
la jeunesse et la 39 ans certain nombre
d'idées et un pays qui est paralysé
depuis pas mal d'années et qui espèrent
tous de ce président du conseil donc il
ya une conjonction d'événements est
assez extraordinaire
écrit en français c'est beaucoup plus
difficile après les résultats des
élections municipales et européennes
c'est difficile d'imaginer
françois hollande de se lancer dans les
formes comme sauveur le chef du
gouvernement italien n'a pas hésité à
passer en force sur certains dossiers
mais sans jamais faire face à plus de
trois jours de grève et malgré tout les
italiens ont majoritairement voté pour
son parti aux dernières élections
européennes
prochaine étape pour matteo renzi mettre
en place le contrat unique une réforme
qui semble impossible en france la vraie
difficulté c'est la réforme du marché du
travail parce que c'est compliqué tout
ça est difficile compliqué et il faut
trouver un bon équilibre
ça va hurler dans tous les sens ça va
sans payet mais je pense que c'est
vraiment nécessaire je pense qu'on va y
arriver une réforme qui pour l'heure
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour de
l'exécutif depuis des années la droite
souhaite s'attaquer à ce dossier mais
jusqu'ici sans succès
voilà jean philippe jauniaux de l'
agence france-presse
alors à propos du pacte de
responsabilité lapsus vous parlez de
vous parler d'austérité donc après du
pack de responsabilité est ce qu'il faut
garder les déficits tels qu'ils sont
comment réduire un déficit mais je
rappeler une chose on nous parle
essentiellement du déficit budgétaire
c'est ça dont on nous parle les fameux 3
% qu'il faut atteindre 0 5% de déficit
structurel et c'est par 0% à terme mais
la dette publique continue à augmenter
ça nous en parle pas pourtant
théoriquement il ya un plafond de 60% on
nous en parle pas parce qu'elles
continuent à augmenter comme moi je suis
à cause des déficits elle augmente aussi
parce que il n'ya pas de recettes
fiscales qui rend très bien vu qu'à 14
milliard 600 millions de recettes
fiscales en moins l'année dernière grâce
augmenté augmenter la sq maintenant cela
dit on peut très bien diminuer les
déficits si on a plus de croissance si
on a un taux de croissance plus fort
donc si on a un total peut y avoir de
politique économique quelle politique
économique on mène si on a un taux de
croissance économique plus fort ça
génère des recettes fiscales ça génère
des recettes sociales et on peut
diminuer lé déficit et on voit très bien
que pour atteindre les 3% c'est quand
même la galère même la cour des comptes
dit que avoir les atteindre a pas et
c'est
toujours
sagement doute on pressent déjà tout le
monde on n'est même pas aux 3% et la
dette continuent à augmenter donc c'est
une fausse route mais pour atteindre 3%
de croissance aussi c'est la galère
c'est pas favoris parce que la
difficulté de cette crise qui n'est pas
terminée depuis 2007 c'est l'été 2007
qu'elle s'est déclenchée en 2008 la
difficulté de cette crise et qu'elle
demande des résolutions au niveau 1 pour
partie internationale pour partie
européenne par par exemple au niveau
européen l'ensemble des syndicats
européens on a formulé l'idée de d'un
plan de relance européen à hauteur de 2%
du produit intérieur brut dans les
infrastructures les investissements au
mur nous dire ces sympathiques votre
truc mais ça se fait pas d'une manière
ou d'une autre on a vu deux les débats
sur le budget européen etc et après il
ya des dispositions nationales donc on
est partout dans des logiques
d'austérité faut débloquer l'austérité
auxquelles vous avez des alliés au sein
même du groupe ps à l'assemblée le ce
qu'on appelle les frondeurs est-ce que
vous pensez que peu qu'ils peuvent
mettre en minorité le pack où ça ne veut
pas rentrer là dedans parce que moi je
peux je ne fais pas de politique je fais
du syndicalisme
non mais je regarde moi je suis curieux
de tout
moi je ne cherche pas nos rites et les
majorités moi je regarde attendait
certes 40 quand certains de ce qu'on
appelle les frondeurs 10 attendez si on
continue une politique 41 milliard pour
les entreprises sur trois ans cinq
milliards pour les ménages on va
accentuer l'austérité et ça va avoir un
caractère récessif je note que beaucoup
d'économistes expliquent sympa tous les
libéraux disent pas ça mais les
keynésiens 10 bah oui c'est un effet
récessif ce pacte de responsabilité
d'austérité donc il faut aussi soutenir
la demande sur le principe oui je suis
d'accord pour donner plus de
compétitivité pour les entreprises c'est
bien pour doper la croissance n'ont en
revanche pas moins franchement
le talent et la compétitivité c'est quoi
là il ya on a un pacte de responsabilité
focaliser sur 20% du coût global des
entreprises faut baisser les faut
baisser le coût du travail il faut
baisser le coût du travail le reste on
n'en parle plus donc il ya d'autres
choses à faire que de baisser le coût du
travail est d'entrer dans une logique et
une logique de dumping vous savez par
exemple ils ont annoncé toute une série
d'exonérations de cotisations on ne sert
à chaque fois je lui mets notamment sur
l'est pour les salariés ouais bon juste
après moi j'aurais préféré exemple entre
le smic franchement c'est beaucoup plus
simple que de remettre une usine à gaz
c'est quand même la première fois qu'un
gouvernement quelle que soit sa couleur
politique va baisser une cotisation
salariale sur les retraites on nous dit
à des problèmes de retraite mais on
baisse la cotisation salariale des
salariés pour que le type ou la fille
qui est au smic et 500 votre plus à la
fin de l'année il salue augmenter le
smic quand je dis mais pourquoi vous
n'augmentez pas le smic à parce que si
on augmente le smic on donne un élément
contraires à notre politique est une
abaissement du coût du travail s'est
inquiété pour les contreparties en
termes d'économies budgétaires mais
combien compensation et les comprendre
moi je n'ai plus loin encore ouais elle
propose de baisser elle dit qu'on n'a
pas encore touché à masse salariale de
fonction publique qu'il ya trop de
mesures pour les bas salaires qu'il faut
avoir été d'embaucher dans l'éducation
nationale
alors est-ce que c'est enfin ils vont
pas dans votre sens du tout oui monsieur
migaud aime ça migaud aime ça démarre
par n et puis ben on l'appellera madame
thatcher côté il va dans une logique en
tant que président de la cour des
comptes mais aussi président du haut
conseil de finances publiques dans une
logique et une logique d'austérité parmi
lesquelles ces risques ou non me soit
bon il est comptable aux combes et
j'aime bien les comptables mais dans ce
sens là j'aime pas trop parce que là ce
massif auteurs il ya un côté oui
attendait il faut continuer il faut
baisser les services publics il faut
afin qu est ce qu il sait monsieur milou
sait peut-être pas parce qu'il n'a pas
l'occasion de le voir est ce qu'il c'est
monsieur mikucki quand on voit dans les
départements que quand vous avez des
services publics qui ferment et y en a
de plus en plus des services publics qui
ferment si les républicains il devrait
est attaché à la présence de proximité
des services publics là il sait à 3% à
la fois y aller faut y aller faut y
aller il ya trop de fonctionnaires ont
des galas républicain il n'est pas de
gomez au nom je me savais qu'il est de
gauche qui n'est pas de gauche moi ça ne
compte pas donc qui est droite qui n'est
pas de droite républicain on peut être
de gauche ou droite d'ailleurs n'est pas
obligatoirement d'un côté ou de l'autre
quand on est attaché aux valeurs
républicaines mais pour moi être attaché
aux valeurs républicaines c'est aussi
assurer une présence du service public
tant vis-à-vis des usagers citoyens que
vis-à-vis des entreprises on ya déjà
toute une série de services publics qui
ont disparu quand vous discutez avec oud
et directeur administration voire des
ministres en charge de ministères
combien vous disent mais c'est pas les
premiers de dire mais on sait plus
comment faire on est à l'os on n'arrive
plus à gérer et là on continue à dire
maintenant même mal et il faut continuer
à baisser les effigies mégots qui n'est
aussi que nous sommes à l'os mais il
parle du budget de l'état et dit par
exemple le gel du point d'indicé pour
les fonctionnaires que vous combattez
des javas ça ne va pas assez loin
les keynésiens c'est un libéral qui
sourit je vous dise moi bah oui on n'a
pas la même conception économique moi je
retiens sur les primes des
fonctionnaires oui mais on va agir aussi
sur les salaires ou sais pas comment ça
les traitements des conseillers la cour
des comptes on peut faire ça pour gagner
pineau 200 au total bon mais il faut
arrêter la fonction publique ne peut pas
être plus efficace avec moins de
salariés mais c'est pas ça le problème
le problème ça fait quand même sept ans
je disais au premier ministre lors de la
réunion de conférence mais deux méthodes
cette semaine ça fait sept ans qu'on
demande un débat sur le rôle et les
missions du service public le président
précédent s'est engagé il l'a pas fait
conférence sociale l'année dernière 2013
on nous dit oui ça y est ça va démarrer
tout de suite un an et toujours rien de
fait voilà donc on n'a pas le débat
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est avec lui
qu'elle mission il doit assurer après on
regarde ça c'est le service public qu'il
assure c'est l'état c'est la région et
ses vrais débats n'ont pas lieu par
contre en coupe bon ben ok puis alors on
peut augmenter aussi c'est ce que dit la
cour des comptes qui propose d'augmenter
la durée effective du travail dans la
fonction publique dont il en veut nous
dire que le travail ils font les fonds
de tiroir un oui comme s'il est très
nette et les fonctionnaires travaillent
et pas assez c'est ce qu'on nous dit oui
mais voyez l'image que l'on donne enfin
écoutez c'est quand même incroyable
discuter avec moi j'en vois
régulièrement des salariés de demain je
suis dans une entreprise du privé après
demain je verrai des salaires du privé
parfois je vois des fonctionnaires
attendait tous 10 mai dans les finances
partout on est au près sûr et on a du
mal à faire le boulot etc
se rendre compte des difficultés c'est
vrai la sécu et la sécu c'est pas de la
fonction publique c'est d'une convention
c'est du droit privé partout ça serre
les boulons au point où c'est y compris
des emplois bien sûr mais c'est même pas
une question de statut uniquement ses on
a du service public qui fout le camp
côté caen par exemple prenez hors
fonction lui que les urssaf on a
régionalisé les urssaf les urssaf quand
ils sont plus près du terrain ne peuvent
plus conseiller les entreprises c'est
devenu un tiroir-caisse passer à autre
chose
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
confidente conférence sociale de 2013
vous estimez qu'il n'y a pas eu assez de
retombée depuis et vous avez dit hier
que c'était un exercice usées ouais
alors pourquoi vous y allé battre et
c'est un exercice usées parce que
j'avais dit l'année dernière que c'était
long de jours alors on a gagné une demi
journée c'est déjà ça ça fera une
journée et demie au lieu de deux jours
mais quand c'est quand j'ai dit ça use
et oui la première bon il ya venue de
voir les élections tout le monde de
discuter voilà les chantiers qu'on va
faire et cetera on va arrêter la rgpp
mais ils ont continué bas la deuxième
déjà c'était déjà du mal à discuter
salaires et c'est donc ce que j'ai dis
pas qu'on va motiver pourquoi enfin
quand j'y serai mais toutes les militant
es fou qu'ils y sont et je les dis au
président nous on va avec le cahier de
revendications donc dans toulon va
déposer les revendications noir donc
relation les salaires
l'epargne salariale pour nous c'est pas
une priorité parce que le patronat
demande que le gouvernement sembl
accéder la modernisation ce qu'ils
appellent la modernisation et avec
social fait quatre ans qu'on en discute
tu vas nous resservir ça ça veut dire
plus de flexibilité qu on le veuille ou
non c'est pas une priorité pour françois
hier le service public la protection va
déposer les revendications bon après
qu'est ce qu'il en sortira j'avais dit
si jamais c'est une conférence consacrée
aux pas de responsabilité nous n'irons
pas prémunissent dit non ce n'est pas
une conférence consacrée aux impacts de
responsabilité la question du pacte de
responsabilité sera évoqué le début de
la conférence dans la rencontre entre
les syndicats le patronat et le
président de la république donc j'aurai
l'occasion de dire en face au président
de la république tout le mal que je
pense du pack devedjian
nature mais
sinon on parle de jouer et puis à côté
il ya un décalage depuis et puis c'est
quand même ça fait 6 mois 1 qu'il a
c'est pas le 14 janvier tout le monde
dit l'annoncé le 14 janvier ben moi j'ai
une bonne mémoire encore c'est le 31
décembre vous êtes impatients
dernière j'avais dit il ya ceux qui
soutiennent blum quand blum j'avais dit
ça au président n'a plus gagné à dire
qu'en blum disait nous serons les
gestionnaires honnêtes et loyaux des
affaires du capitalisme jamais dit que
nous ont préféré jaurès puisque jaurès
disait faut le courage c'est de chercher
la vérité et de la dire et de ne pas
subir la loi du mensonge triomphant qui
passe près en public m'a coupé dernier
en disant oui mais blum à gouverner et
je lui ai répondu oui jaurès n'a pas eu
le temps l'assassiner voyez déjà les y
en a eu il ya bientôt question à votre
dialogue renouvelé avec le chef de
l'état pour parler juillet aux
personnalités françois rebsamen vous
aviez salué sa nomination quand il est
arrivé au ministère du travail il ya
deux mois et demi
il est décrit par certains comme
dilettante que ne connaissant pas ses
dossiers qu'est ce que l'on écouté ça
pourrait être un bon ministre du travail
on n'est pas obligatoirement un
technicien du travail on peut être un
technicien du travail à être aussi un
bon ministre françois rebsamen
connaît le rapport de forces c'est un
homme politique au bon sens quand j'ai
eu mon sens du terme qui sait ce que
c'est que discuter qui sait ce que c'est
que négociée qui sait écouter non
seulement écouter mais qui sait entendre
non moi je considère et la grande idée
non je suis pas toujours d'accord mais
c'est carrément parler des seuils et
avait pour mémoire il a dit bon bah on
verra dans la négociation si vous en
reparler moi je lui ai dit écoutez c'est
une connerie a pour moi c'est le relais
s'est empressé il veut suspendre les
seuils dans les entreprises oui à partir
de 10 salariés en raison temps syndical
à partir de 50 comités d'entreprise nous
on essaye d'effectifs qui sont des
freins à l'embauché des patrons et donc
françois rebsamen ça fait 30 ans qu'on
attend ça mais vous accepté de parler
quand même de ça ou non mon nouveau
seuil nous ce qu'on a toujours et sans
jamais en parler parce qu'il vous
demande d'en parler oui l'intérêt ici on
va voir comment ça se passe si si ça
rentre dans une négociation ça prend des
coups et des négociations sur la
modernisation du dialogue social dont
l'un des objets vous n'êtes deux objets
serait de remettre en cause les seuils
quand on se dit partisan dialogue social
empêcher qu il est délégué du personnel
à partir de 11 juin c'est à partir de 50
ça me paraît curieux et dans le même
temps ce serait quoi la contrepartie on
va discuter de la carrière des militants
syndicaux mais je me vois pas un faux
pas de minutes il a lancé je sais pas
dans quelles conditions banques au
moment où ils en parlent plus bon bah
c'est très bien qu'il en parle plus on
verra dans les jours à venir mais non
mais moi je continue à dire dans la
relation c'est un bon ministre avec des
mots c'est que c'était une femme une
proposition personnelle ou que ça venait
du gouvernement on attendait cette
traîne dans les tiroirs depuis un bout
de temps tu sais c'est que ça traîne
dans les tiroirs depuis un bout de temps
il avait évoqué plus ou moins il avait
bon est ce qu'il avait dit clairement
comme ça j'en sais rien je n'étais pas
là quand il ordonnait l'interview mais
bon il en parle moins en tous les cas
pas
silence notamment par certains membres
du gouvernement et par le patron du ps
jean-christophe cambadélis qui a dit qu'
il ne le suivaient pas du tout sur cette
histoire de seuil jean philippe
chainieux merci perrine tarneaud de
public sénat arrive maintenant juste
après ce détour gars par la conférence
mensuelle que pia gattaz a tenu ce matin
un patron de combat dit-on camilla
campus anneaux
franc-parler fermeté pierre gattaz
impose son style depuis une dizaine de
mois la méthode ne change pas à quelques
jours de la troisième conférence sociale
le medef fervent défenseur du dialogue
social à condition qu'ils aillent dans
son sens - rigidifier la législation du
travail
parce que vous savez que c'est l'un des
deux épouvantails majeurs du pays une
législation de travail extrêmement
complexe anxiogène qui fait que les
patrons peur d'embaucher encore et qui
fait que nos salariés ont peur d'être
licencié l'autre domaine de la fiscalité
qui là aussi il faut simplifier et et
retrouver une fiscalité incitative et
motivante plus provocateurs à ses débuts
pour marquer sa différence aujourd'hui
il ne faudrait pas faire échouer le
pacte de responsabilité
ses conseillers en communication
verrouille le discours mais le naturel
reprend
pidement le des studios quand j'entends
encore des phrases comme cadeau aux
entreprises cadeaux aux patrons je pense
que ces gens là n'ont toujours pas
compris et j'aimerais que ces gens là un
jour créé un seul emploi créé deux
emplois créés cinq emplois créés disant
toi et qu'ils reviennent nous voir après
pour nous expliquer si nous avions
raison susan ont tort une manière de
faire monter la pression cette méthode
induit un rapport de force qui n'a rien
d'exceptionnel selon l'ancien ministre
du travail une méthode qui ne remettrait
pas en question le dialogue social je
vois un medef qui porte les
préoccupations des chefs d'entreprise le
dialogue est plus que jamais nécessaire
y compris en période de tension en
période de tension se renfermer c'est la
pire des choses dialoguer ça ne veut pas
dire reculer ça veut dire aussi
convaincre partager le dialogue social
c'est un rendez vous obligatoire pour
moderniser et réformer notre pays qui en
a bien besoin ne pas reculer aucun doute
pour pierre gattaz il l'avait annoncé
dès son élection il veut un medef de
combat un simple jeu de rôle selon cette
spécialiste
il faut peut-être année ça me rapporte
que c'est un tout petit peu plus large
qui est celui vannes l'arrivée du
président hollande et du nouveau
gouvernement en 2012 donc le combat ça
veut dire évidemment faire avancer les
idées qui sont les nôtres et qu'on
défend savait pas forcément le dire
ne pas tenir compte de l'autre partie ou
écraser les adversaires des adversaires
qui se rejoignent sur un point une des
priorités à négocier l'emploi des jeunes
voilà perrine tarneaud nous à rejoindre
encore perrine question au secrétaire
général de force
alors sur pierre gattaz à ce que le
medef sous l'ère gattaz s'est
radicalisée selon vous obama au moins
d'enjeux pendant tant d la cdu du
discours etc oui il ya une certaine
forme de posture plus rigide je dirais
que avec madame parisot même si on a eu
aussi des discussions
sévère avec madame parisot à l'époque
mais oui c'est le style est différent et
sentiment que bon peut-être parce qu'il
ya eu des pigeons puisque toute une
série de choses qui a une forme de
radicalisation du discours patronal oui
mais qui va au delà de pierre gattaz des
patrons dans l'ensemble vous trouvez pas
que tous les patrons vous savez tous les
patrons tous les chefs d'entreprise sont
pas adhérents medef où la cgpme il a
beaucoup qui sont adhérents du parrain
et donc tous les patrons ne sent pas
dans cette situation mais du côté du
patronat oui il ya une forme du discours
plus dur ils défendent la revendication
patronale comme quoi les classes
sociales ça existe encore c'est
peut-être normal aussi sous une
présidence maintenant de gauche
socialiste ce qui n'était pas le mien je
rentre dans les testicules parce que
ouais les et les politiques économiques
sont pas si différentes que ça
sort là sur la ligne de la politique
économique globale non il ya des petites
inflexion n'y a pas vraiment de
différence attendez le socialiste de
l'offre ou la compétitivité face à peu
près les mêmes choses rien n'a changé
depuis l'élection france assure la ligne
générale de politiques économiques nous
en ce moment nous voir on suit la ligne
sarkozy c'est exactement la même que
celle de france ne suis pas sûre en
terme de politique
économique du coup il n'y a pas de
différence franchement donc sarkozy
hollande sur la ligne même combat oui
bah ça il n'y a pas que il n'ya pas
qu'en france d'ailleurs on voit ça dans
pas mal de pays aujourd'hui c'est sous
l'effet de ce qu'on accepte au niveau
européen sme et vous diriez que la
droite et la gauche finalement
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose c'est un
peu le 10e rang général ambiant non je
bats l'ump le ps et la même chose
aujourd'hui on se rende pas dans les les
étiquettes non dans les noms y compris
dans les éthique je ne parle que de
politique économique et sociale
après le reste c'est autre chose moi je
ne m'occupe pas du reste heures jeudi
syndicales politiques et la même époque
il ya des nuances mais sur le fond je
n'ai pas le sentiment que le à non je
n'ai pas le sentiment que le
gouvernement mène une politique
keynésienne par exemple d'accord est-ce
que selon vous la cfdt doit se
désolidariser du pacte de responsabilité
pour ne pas cautionner certaines sorties
du medef où ça c'est leur problème ils
se sont engagés cfdt dans par un relevé
de décisions qui d'ailleurs aucune
valeur juridique et qu'entre nous un bon
ils se sont engagés à soutenir le pack
de responsabilités moi dès le départ
j'ai dit c'est un marché de dupes et je
crois que jusque maintenant on voit bien
que c'est un marché du puisque on ne
peut pas exiger de contrepartie sur une
aide générale et il ya des contreparties
en termes d'emploi nous attendons les
discussions qui ont lieu dans les
branches déjà comment elle va commencer
bah oui ça commence mais vous prenez
dans nous c'est de soutenir la décision
vous reprenez l'agenda qui avait été
discuté dans la branche et puis vous dit
bon on va regarder on va évaluer etc
mais c'est pas les engrais c'est pas
beau ça pierre gattaz a toujours son pin
fait un million d'emplois ah bah oui
mais non ils souhaitent être commandé
beaucoup il faut bien qu'ils les
utilisent ça c'est de la com un million
dans quoi tu es ridicule moins fine la
com et un engagement de sa part n'est
pas objectivement attendait un objectif
oui bah il finira par avoir raison
j'espère dans le temps chez pas de camp
sur un million d'employés noirs combien
détruit enfin ça c'est de la com ça
franchement je ne pense pas de jambes et
la cfdt s'est engagée dans une voie sans
issue
moi j'ai toujours dit que j'ai vu qu'on
n'était pas d'accord donc en dessous il
faut bien comprendre quand vous vous
engagez à soutenir un pacte dit de
responsabilité et de solidarité c'est
nouveau le nouveau mot qui était accolé
dans le même temps y compris la reprise
en mains publiques l'expliquent ça quand
il était chez bourdin il l'a expliqué
dans le même temps vous avalisez les 50
milliards d'euros de réduction des
dépenses publiques et sociales les deux
sont liés on peut pas dire comme le dit
laurent berger non on est pour le pack
de responsable mais quand les 50
milliards gino mon gars tu as signé
c'est pour les deux c'est pas pour un
seul truc lui laurent berger il dit se
défend le syndicalisme de proposition
contre la radicalité inutiles qui
dégradent qui dégradent pardon l'image
des syndicats voulaient répondez quoi
bâtir des femmes c'est encore ce sont
des mots moi je dis toujours lancer des
mots assez forts oui bah comme pas comme
gattaz voilà bon écoutez quand on est
militant syndicaliste qu'on est
réformiste françois y avait une
organisation réformiste depuis tout le
temps autour de mets moins l'image de la
pression
ils sont parfois mis son informateur
c'est autre chose il veut réformer la
société là j'ai posté formateur vous
voulez réformer la société moi je n'ai
pas ce enfin en tant que syndicat on on
se donne pas ce rôle nous on est là pour
questions particulières relevant des
intérêts des salariés bon donc et quand
on est d'accord et bandits ont sinon
prendre responsable et exemple sur
l'assurance chômage ou sur d'autres
accords quand on n'est pas d'accord on
le dit aussi nettement quand même c'est
toujours moi un syndicat qui dit
toujours vie comme un syndicat qui dit
toujours non c'est pas normal donc vous
n'avez pas l'impression que vous nuisez
ainsi en ce sens vous imposant sur sa
couenne si on peut ranger à l'image des
syndicats mais nous en soucier
75% je peux comprendre que quand vous
êtes gêné quand il ya une grève on en
parlait tout à l'heure vous êtes gêné
sur une grève oui vous n'avez pas envie
puis peut-être que les motifs ne sont
pas toujours bien compris ça c'est autre
chose maintenant on ne gère pas les
responsables syndicaux dans leurs
instances on a des instances dans les
organes où on ne gère pas ça en fonction
des sandales savez à force de gérer en
fonction des sondages on voit il nous
amène les politiques quand valls dit la
gauche peut mourir on envie quand même
de se poser la question est ce que les
syndicats aussi peuvent mourir pourtant
cure des salariés il y aura des
syndicats donc comme le nombre de
salariés globalement ne diminue pas du
syndicalisme sur le rac toujours à des
singes et des partis politiques y en
aura toujours non il y en a un petit pas
mais quand vous entrez que le premier
ministre socialiste quand même dit que
la gauche peut mourir est ce que ça vous
interpelle vous en tant que syndicaliste
non j'ai pas de commentaires à faire en
tant que syndicaliste sur ce genre
d'affirmations qui il a dit ça devant
son parti politique c'est leur
responsabilité alors peut-être parler
d'autres réformes qui sont en cours
actuellement j'avais envie de vous
parler de la réforme du permis de
conduire qui vient d'être présenté par
le ministre de l'intérieur à partir de
2015 la surveillance de l'examen du code
de la route sera privatisée c'est à dire
que les syndicats d'inspecteurs du
permis
vont être privatisées ils sont pas
contents ils menacent d'une grève ils
vont décider prochainement d'ailleurs de
leur comportement de leur comportement
est ce que vous êtes pour une grève est
ce que vous êtes pour faire capoter de
notre forme qu'est ce que moi j'ai pris
une fois je comprends plus manuel valls
ministre de l'intérieur avait donc en
responsabilité le permis de conduire il
s'est engagé en tant que pénis de
l'intérieur à préserver le service
public du permis de conduire s'écrie on
à la lettre est ce que manuel valls
premier ministre dément manuel valls
ministre de l'intérieur je parle même
pas du condo matt candidat hollande
pendant la campagne électorale et les
poires alors premiers éléments donc moi
je voudrais comprendre déjà est ce que
là il ya un changement un contre-pied
après c'est quoi le problème c'est que
le problème des gangs
qui est gérée il ya quelque chose qui
est juste un objectif qui bon qui est de
dire il faut essayer de réduire le coût
du permis pour les jeunes et il faut
essayer que les délires les rsa on est
d'accord donc il faut augmenter
surveillants qu'est ce qu'ils demandent
par exemple les inspecteurs du permis de
conduire ils demandent ils ont évalué à
150 sur le nombre total d'inspecteurs
nécessaire pour pouvoir effectivement
réduire le délai comment répondre
gouvernement on peut pas embaucher sans
cela les caisses sont vides vous avez
entendu didier migaud à la retraite
non mais je vous rappelle quand même
qu'il ya eu 7500 postes qui n'ont pas
été pourvus parce qu'ils n'ont pas
budgété en fait il nous raconte des
histoires et disent que c'est parce
qu'elle plaide jean concours on peut pas
dégager 150 postes de permis de conduire
alors comme on peut pas dégager 150
postes qu'est ce qu'il explique monsieur
cazeneuve il explique donc on va
privatiser une partie on va combattre
d'abord
responsable à des retraités des
gendarmes et c'est à chaque fois cet
effet s'est pas marché donc ça méritait
après un prêt oui mais c'est une fin des
privatisations méridien entreprises qui
se pointe et après qu'est ce qui va se
passer sur les rd contre ça très fort
écoutez que dans tous les cas s'est
prononcée brut de fonderie sans
discussion préalable un truc qui
apparaît boucler un donc le minimum des
choses déjà c'est d'en discuter un bon
l'objectif est louable mais les moyens
n'ont alors pour mieux faire le service
public on privatise et les trucs que je
comprends pas non plus ah bah ça peut
être un bras de fer avec le gouvernement
oui et en plus il justifie sa réforme
monsieur quasiment dix ans mais tout ça
ça nous permettra d'économiser 200
postes c'est bien qu'on en a besoin les
postes mais ils n'ont pas les moyens de
donner 150 ou 200 inspecteurs de tout
nécessaire en plus pour faire le boulot
pour fear is gens préfèrent c'est pas
moi qui
il ya un mécontentement parce que moi
j'ai france ouvrière est majoritaire aux
danses les inspecteurs du permis de
conduire je sais qu'ils sont pas
contents après c'est eux qui vont
décider de mon comportement moi je suis
pas pdg un cd syndicat qui dit si
sociale pour finir cette émission jean
claude mailly celui plus corporatiste
aussi un des taxis est ce que ça c'est
pas un combat d'arrière garde à écouter
les taxis 20 sujets bien où je connais
pas le dans le détail le dossier mais en
tous les cas ils veulent des garanties
et quand vous avez acheté des plats très
très cher et cetera que vous vous êtes
endettés pendant très longtemps cédé à
200 300 mille euros la plaque ils
veulent des conditions de régulation
correct or apparemment c'est pas le cas
donc je connais pas le détail des
dossiers mais je sais que ça a grogné
encore ces derniers temps là dessus très
bien donc là également pour les soutenir
bah écoutez sur les expressions qu'ils
ont eues on a des adhérents il faut dans
les taxis qui ont été dans des
manifestations ils veulent des garanties
quand vous prenez des crédits
succès pour être franc c'est à regarder
le détail de la composition de loi voyez
bien que ça fait quand même pas mal de
dents droit pour des raisons diverses où
il ya des tensions moi ce que je dis
depuis pas mal de temps attention aucune
tension toutes ces tensions ça peut
déboucher sur moi mais je dit on sans
raison
c'est non seulement socialement
suicidaire ça en france comme ailleurs
économiquement suicidaire et on l'a vu
ces derniers temps ça peut être
démocratiquement suicidaire c'est pas
que je suis de vin quand je dis ça si je
pensais depuis longtemps si je pense ça
depuis longtemps je pense qu'à l'elysée
on en est conscient la bonne question
qu'il faut se poser c'est pourquoi
continuer la même politique jean claude
mailly merci d'avoir été fait merci
farine bonsoir à tous et à très vite